Abraham Lincoln's humility comes from a
lot of places but it probably starts
with his sense of empathy we know a
remarkable amount about him for someone
who was born in the early 19th century
even when he was a child he demonstrated
extraordinary empathy and willingness to
reach out to people around him even to
animals and that's it's hard to imagine
what though what sort of the Old West
was like but this is this is an era one
sort of torturing animals for fun and
for sport was a casual that everybody
did that and we have many sort of quite
reliable stories that he not only
absolutely refused to participate in
that but would stop other people from
doing it when he saw it something that
was sort of remarked upon as a strange
characteristic from this young boy so I
think it started with empathy and
another ailment will probably be
deprived that he clearly suffered from
chronic clinical depression at least
twice his friends put him on suicide
watch and when you think about think
about what it took to be put on suicide
watch in the nineteenth century will
give you a sense of just how severe the
depression probably was who wants one
seven I am the most miserable man living
so I think these two things were part of
it and there was this sense in him that
he was Lincoln that was not grandiose
but he did not lack for a sense of
destiny that he thought that there that
he had been he in his first sort of
really long speech it's called the
Lyceum address it's sort of law florid
and overstated and completely
uncharacteristic of Lincoln style and
he's very young and he's probably trying
to impress the people in his community
when he gives this talk so he sort of
overstates everything but it's still
linked own Ian it still has an
extraordinary psychological insight and
what what he says is this very
conventional start side he says you know
what are the great threats to American
democracy and institutions this is a
sort of a hackneyed speaking topic in
those days and it starts out very
conventional East it's look the United
States is now so strong that every
European Army combined could not
possibly challenge us
so the threats are all internal then I
think surprising about that but here's
where we get the Lincoln the only con
insight he says that the problem here is
that every nation create brings up
people of towering ambition
his word with a thirst and a hunger for
renown and this is this is this again is
this an idea then that Alexander
Hamilton once said that the hunger for
renown is the enduring hallmark of the
noblest Minds for fame not celebrities
we think of now but fame this is that
historians will write about you and what
you did and Lincoln says that when the
United States was founded you could
secure this eternal Fame by
strengthening its institutions by making
it a success he says but now the success
is assured we are a success and you
don't get eternal fame by assuring the
success of something that's already
successful says you get it by changing
the world this is that that every nation
produces not Napoleon's people of this
kind of ambition and they're not gonna
want to do this anymore they're gonna
want to overturn although the old
institutions to change the world and
says these people have this drive this
unstoppable drive and this is the moment
when it gets particularly given from
Lincoln's now particularly haunting says
and they will do it they will get this
right noun whether it be by freeing
slaves or enslaving freemen so when you
hear a very very young early you know
mid 20s Abraham Lincoln talking about
freeing slaves this is a pretty
remarkable thing to hear and so I think
Lincoln had this sense that he was you
know that he was in part an agent of a
larger destiny and that it was this
drive for renown that made him you know
that suited him for this capacity of
being this agent but in doing so he also
understood that he was an avatar right
he was the he was part of the cause but
the cause was not him and in that sort
of deeper ability willingness to
acknowledge that there was much more
going on than just the story of Abraham
Lincoln I think he became he became
humble in a way that almost transcends
our normal vision of humility right we
think of someone as humble that they
deferential or or willing willing to
defer to other people that's not it it's
humble in the sense of of a person who
is doing something Noble
and worthwhile but it is the noble quest
is far more important